like all comic-book universes DC Comics
is made up of a sprawling canon of fan
favorites and total busts on one hand
you got your Holy Trinity of Superman
Batman and Wonder Woman on the other
hand you've got the likes of Pandora
Azrael or Jason Todd as Robin
everyone has their favorites their worst
sand firsts but what about lifelong
comics fan and comic actor Jason Mewes
we had the opportunity to speak with
muse
aka Jay of Jay and Silent Bob Fame while
he was promoting his film madness in the
method which he stars in and directed as
his debut feature behind the camera
knowing that he knows his stuff when it
comes to comic books we asked him for
his take on the three best and three
worst characters DC Comics has to offer
we're going powerhouses I mean again I
have my favorites but again I won't say
that the strongest but I'd have to say
for a team Batman Superman and Martian
Manhunter because that marshmallow to me
has just as much power and such as
Superman he does have weaknesses but he
can turn intangible and invisible and
such Muse was clear that with his
selection of favorites he mostly went
for raw strength over scrappy
personality and that he might personally
prefer some characters who don't hit
quite so hard
I love Deadshot - as a character
Deadshot it's one of my favorite
characters and vigilante but they're not
very you know after selecting his top
three muse had a surprising amount of
trouble getting into the DC Comics
characters he likes least in general the
real-life Jay doesn't seem to dislike
much of anything when it comes to fandom
he's like a living embodiment of that
one song from the lego movie I would say
worse characters I mean I know I think
there is worse characters I mean again
that's there they're all sort of awesome
but then in a Eureka moment he started
seeing double and found two of his worst
in one shot freaking Wonder Twins I mean
I know they could turn into most things
but in the cartoon they only turn into
like water and ice and hawks and stuff
I'm sure they could turn maybe into like
dragons and
maybe something cooler but maybe not so
those two are the worst off the top of
my head
you were terrific sand first a wave now
a drip so that's two sorries in and Jana
but when it comes to superhero tier
lists apparently you're down there with
the likes of King Tut no they're worse I
would say I don't know why I'm not a fan
of this like we're going old school like
King Tut or like I'm not a fan of the
penguin I know he was sort of cool but
not really in selecting his three worst
DC characters mu spent a lot of time
expounding on the comic book brands
villains which he says includes some of
his favorite comic book characters in
general a particular note for him
outside of his top three is the whole
collection of Batman's rogues gallery
including to face the Riddler and all
the other fiends and foes who tend to
cross paths with justice in Gotham City
it's not just what they do in comics
cartoons it on film that makes the meat
to him it's also the toy sets they end
up in which he has a habit of collecting
their rogues I would say from DC and
Batman I mean I love I love all like the
sets they have again going from me for
collecting toys like the rogues gallery
and stuff Clayface and Joker poison ivy
all that stuff are pretty awesome and
then again I love Suicide Squad from the
comics you know so Harley Quinn is
pretty cool and Joker and Deadshot's on
that team not The Fresh Prince of Bel
Air's dead shop
y'all Joker's must be crazy outside of
his top and bottom three it's clear Muse
knows a thing or two about DC Comics
characters probably as much if not more
than the actors who actually play them
in adapted form on screen he's an actor
so it begs the question would he ever
want to suit up the play a DC Comics
hero or a villain himself I would say no
because I love like I'm not saying I
would turn them down but I don't think
I'd want to play a character because I
love watching the movies the TV shows oh
so much on top of checking out Jason
Mewes directorial debut madness in the
method out now via video on demand you
can also see him in the upcoming of you
ask universe sequel Jay and Silent Bob
reboot touring the United States in a
roadshow format starting October 15th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book characters are
coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]